tengo esta función localmente
discontinua a la que llamaremos fx ajá
entonces bueno mi meta es intentar
dibujar su derivada aquí entonces quiero
que pienses en la pendiente de la línea
tangente la la pendiente en cada punto
de esta curva y bueno voy a intentar lo
mejor posible de dibujar su pendiente
entonces ataquemos el problema aquí
justo en este punto la pendiente es
positiva en un buen intervalo y mientras
nos alejamos mientras las x crecen la
pendiente sigue positiva pero menos
positiva cada vez luego en este punto
aquí en este punto se hace cero entonces
voy a ver cómo puedo dibujar esto acá
abajo aquí sabemos que la pendiente debe
ser cero y recuerda que yo aquí intenta
de dibujar allí igual a efe prima de x
asumiré que este es un tipo de parábola
estoy aquí y en un momento verás porque
yo debo asumir eso
aquí la pendiente es positiva entonces
bueno la pendiente está más o menos por
aquí luego cada vez es cada vez es menos
positiva cierto asumiré que lo hace de
manera lineal por eso asumo que es una
parábola observa aquí que la pendiente
sigue siendo positiva por lo tanto
cuando veas la derivada la pendiente aún
tendrá un valor positivo como puedes ver
mientras las x van creciendo la
pendiente será cada vez menos positiva
hasta llegar a cero luego la pendiente
se hará cada vez más y más y más y más
negativa entonces en este punto parece
que la pendiente es tan negativa como
positiva del otro lado así que en este
punto la pendiente es tan negativa como
fue positiva acá arriba cierto y bueno
parece razonable todo esto que yo digo
la pendiente de la tangente en este
intervalo visto así parece razonable
ahora pensemos en este otro punto aquí
la pendiente parece constante nuestra
pendiente es un valor
ante mente positivo entonces una vez más
aquí si voy aquí voy a ser cuidadosa
porque en este punto la pendiente no
estará definida realmente porque como tú
puedes observar aquí yo puedo dibujar
múltiples líneas tangentes en este
pequeño punto entonces dibujaré aquí un
pequeño círculo y bueno ahí está la
discontinuidad ahora bien acá tú puedes
ver que la pendiente parece ser positiva
así que la voy a dibujar aunque aunque
no tan positiva como lo fue acá en la
parábola cierto no no fue tan positiva
como acá pero la pendiente es una
constante positiva en todo el intervalo
que abarca tenemos una línea más o menos
la voy a dibujar acá abajo está más o
menos así la línea es una es constante
aquí voy a dibujar unas líneas para para
dejar claro en qué intervalos estoy
trabajando así que voy a borrar aquí
para dejar entonces así más o menos van
quiero que coincida totalmente esto lo
más que se pueda lo voy a hacer lo mejor
que pueda
acabamos de decir que tenemos una
pendiente constante positiva entonces
digamos que que se mira algo de esta
manera luego observamos acá en este
punto justo en este punto nuestra
pendiente está indefinida no hay una
manera de encontrar aquí la pendiente
con esta discontinuidad pero cuando
vamos hacia acá aunque el valor de
nuestra función ha bajado aún tenemos
una pendiente constante positiva de
hecho la pendiente de esta línea aparece
idéntica a la de esta otra línea
entonces continuaremos con esta misma
pendiente una vez más está indefinida
así que en este punto hay discontinuidad
así que pongo un círculo entonces la
pendiente se mirará algo así luego
subimos aquí y el valor de esta función
sube pero ahora la función está plana
por lo tanto la pendiente en este
intervalo es cero entonces lo ponemos
así bueno voy aquí a marcar en este
intervalo bueno voy a marcar el interior
en el cual estoy yo trabajando en este
intervalo la pendiente es 0 y finalmente
en esta última sección la pendiente del
área en otro color color naranja sí
entonces en esta sección la pendiente se
hace negativa pero es una constante
negativa entonces